even like the roasts like the the roast
that Andrew will do so like he just did
the Kanye one yeah yeah but uh man some
of those roast lines are [ __ ] oh dude
they're crazy yeah the Will Smith one oh
it was so good oh yeah and I felt like
we I think we both felt personally like
yo [ __ ] this guy yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then we every he just those roast lines
were crazy I didn't I'm not gonna take
credit for writing those jokes that was
him and uh what like [ __ ] dude those are
great jokes yeah the Will Smith thing
was something where it was like it was
kind of dope to see like uh just all the
comedians just kind of gang up on what
on somebody yeah and it and it was like
it was done in a way that was like
so late like the jokes that came from
right were like maybe it was worth Chris
Rock taking this left for all the comedy
we got out of it
he had
to sat for a night and uh and we got
some great comedic moments from it yo I
really think Will Smith is like he
opened the floodgates for all of the
attacks oh for sure so what's his name
Solomon Rusty getting salmon Rusty
getting uh stabbed on stage that shit's
crazy I think it's this just the girl
getting the beer thrown at her it's all
open now you think that kind of like had
a little bit to do with like having
people get a little you know obviously
uh emboldened to do some [ __ ] like that
yeah this is a crazy crazy comparison
you know how Columbine there weren't
really school shootings and then after
Columbine people were like yo that's a
possibility that's a thing like deranged
people were like oh that's what I did
that was like the first one yeah well in
a much less significant and well I'm not
saying significance the same but like on
a smaller much smaller level people are
at comedy shows and their brain is just
open to the possibility deranged people
are like I could [ __ ] this guy up yeah
and I'm a [ __ ] guy like I'm a very
fuckupable person yeah so I've always
kind of had an awareness of that and
like I never wanted to cross a line I
also don't want to be so disrespectful
that you should beat me up but you won't
because I'm small like I try to play
with the line and I'll say it shows like
hey if you're genuinely if you feel like
I cross the line if you just don't want
me to talk to you just give me something
like this and then we'll move on oh like
like if you do the crowd work thing yeah
yeah but now I'm like I do it earlier
I'm like I need to make sure y'all are
aware of this and then if you give me
this we're not going to try to do this
yeah columbine's kind of like the Sugar
Hill Gang of school shooting
for sure
right it's like
just I said a hip hop first hit the
first hit the first hip hop hit right it
was right
it was like the message
yo it really is it's like weird too
because now like my uh I think it was
one of my nieces was showing me like on
Tick Tock there's like a whole like
underbelly of girls who are like um that
worship like the the shooters like I
don't remember the names of the kids
from Columbine but like there's like a
full like fan girl club of like 19 year
old girls who like you know [ __ ] play
with themselves or looking at pictures
of these dudes or whatever it's pretty
wild but you know what Andrew is a joke
about this every school shooter says the
same thing uh nobody wanted to have sex
with me all these in cells are the ones
that so these girls could be a very
valuable asset you just can't be [ __ ]
the guys you just gotta start [ __ ]
the guys listen to ICP and you know
[ __ ] go off don't shower suck a
couple dicks somebody should do the like
the 4chan grinder you know yeah yeah 100
yes 69 Chan
16. let's do it oh man